the 118th Congress now under Republican
control voted yesterday for the next
speaker of the house and
no one won
Kevin McCarthy was supposed to win
McCarthy has been in house leadership
for over a dozen years he's actually
already started moving his files and
Furniture into the speaker's Suite but
McCarthy did not get the 218 votes
necessary to secure the speakership
which brought the vote to a second
ballot
now McCarthy still didn't have the votes
brought it to a third ballot still
didn't have the votes and then the house
adjourned for the night the whole
episode was somewhat embarrassing
certainly for McCarthy it was even
historic it was the first time in a
hundred years that a speaker election
went to multiple ballots but the one
thing that it was not
was surprising
people are acting shocked right now
especially the establishment Republicans
they are horrified they are clutching
their pearls
I'm not sure why because this is the
exact same thing that happened last time
Republicans had a chance to elect a
speaker back in 2015.
it's the exact same thing
by the exact same people
to the exact same guy
in 2015 when John Boehner stepped down
as Speaker Kevin McCarthy was his
presumptive successor
until some members of the House Freedom
caucus refused to go along with it and
the freedom caucus had enough votes to
block him that election did not go to
multiple ballots but only because
McCarthy bowed out of the race when he
saw that he didn't have the votes
and what happened then
exactly what is happening now
then members of both the establishment
and the freedom caucus called on Paul
Ryan to take the speakership as a
compromise candidate who was acceptable
to both sides a lot of people don't like
Paul Ryan these days because he became
extremely anti-trump and in recent years
has seemed kind of like a squish but at
the time Paul Ryan was considered one of
the more conservative members of the
House
yesterday a new compromise candidate
emerged Jim Jordan great guy strong
conservative Bona fides and also someone
who is not completely unacceptable to
the establishment
and a guy who has backed McCarthy for
speaker
the situation
is pretty much exactly the same we will
see what happens I understand why some
Republicans are backing the freedom
caucus candidate Andy Biggs
I understand why some Republicans are
backing Jim Jordan I even understand why
some Republicans are backing Kevin
McCarthy
the only thing I don't understand is how
all the political Geniuses the
politicians the pundits the
prognosticators how all of them are
completely shocked and appalled that
history is simply repeating itself who
are the holdouts I'm Kevin McCarthy who
are the holdouts these are the people
who are being absolutely maligned tarred
and feathered by the libs and by the
squishes by the Republican establishment
and yet I look down this list of people
who are who are not backing McCarthy
and a lot of them are some of my
absolute favorite members of Congress
so who are the people on here we've got
uh Dan Bishop Lauren bobert Josh
brushing Mike Cloud Andrew Clyde Eli
crane Matt Gates Bob good Paul gosar
Andy Harris Anna Paulina Luna Mary
Miller terrific Ralph Norman Andy ogles
Scott Perry Matt Rosendale chip Roy love
that guy Keith self and and Biggs
seeing like half a dozen names here of
of some of the people that I like most
in Congress
so I think okay
not so bad if they're if they're holding
up maybe they've got good reason to do
that now what the establishment is
saying is this is terrible this is a
horrible embarrassment for the
Republicans I don't why is it an
embarrassment
this used to happen there used to be
contested speaker races it's okay it's
okay guys take a deep breath it's gonna
be all right
we don't we you don't need to get the
speaker on the first ballot we do I have
nothing personally against Kevin
McCarthy really as far as Republican
leadership goes he's far from the worst
guy we've ever seen there but he he
wasn't born with an entitlement to
become the speaker of the house it's all
right in Democratic politics lowercase D
it can be a little bit messy it can be a
little bit untidy people can fight and
battle and try to get their committee
chairmanships and it's all it'll it'll
be just fine guys deep breath this has
happened before in fact this very fight
happened the very last time that
Republicans were able to elect a speaker
what is the debate over
what are the two sides saying right now
a representative Bob good has been going
on TV to give his side of why Kevin
McCarthy should never be the speaker
why won't we vote for Kevin McCarthy
tomorrow he's part of the problem he's
not part of the solution uh there's
nothing about Kevin McCarthy that
indicates that he will bring the change
that's needed to Washington or that's
needed to the Congress or he'll bring
the fight to fight against the Biden
Schumer agenda is worth it to fight for
a few hours or even a few days to get
the best possible person for speaker
all right simple enough he says the
country is in need of dire change Kevin
McCarthy is not sufficiently
conservative and and so we should hash
it out and make sure we pick the right
speaker now now some people are saying
who cares for the speaker is the only
job of the of the speaker of the house
when the opposition party has the Senate
and the White House is just to say no
and to to stall the agenda okay that's
true but I suspect what Bob good and the
other Freedom caucus members are
thinking right now is yeah maybe the the
threshold of candidate that you need
when you are in the in the minority of
the whole government is relatively low
but once someone is established as the
speaker of the house it's not as though
if the Republicans win the Senate and
the White House next time they're just
going to boot the Republican speaker and
elect some new guy
that's not how it works once you get
that position you pretty much stay in
that position so they're saying let's
fight let's get it right now because
this could have long-term consequences
okay what's the other side Newt Gingrich
who was Speaker of the House of
Representatives for the Republicans he
has been going on TV explaining why we
need to elect Kevin McCarthy
team members of their own conference
their conference voted overwhelmingly 85
percent from McCarthy to be speaker so
this is a fight between a handful of
people and the entire rest of the
conference and they're saying they have
the right to screw up everything well
the president that sets is so do the
moderates uh so though the members from
Florida I mean any five people can get
up and say I'm now going to screw up the
conference too the choice is Kevin
McCarthy or chaos and there's nobody
going to replace Kevin because he has
far more people totally dedicated to him
than this handful of never-enders and
the result's going to be anybody who
tried to replace Kevin would face total
chaos it'll be impossible to govern so I
hope in the next 24 hours that these
this handful of members will realize
they don't have the moral right to
reject the choice of 85 percent of their
conference
I love Newt Gingrich but I don't think
his analysis is totally precise here
because it's already happened before
that that's why he says well the vast
majority of the Republicans are
supporting McCarthy and so if they don't
go with McCarthy it's just going to be
sheer cast they're not going to be able
to find a candidate that that's not true
last time the majority of Republicans
were backing McCarthy and then a small
number of Republicans held out and we
got Paul Ryan and Paul Ryan had some
success as a speaker it's true it was
like wrangling cats but that's going to
be true of anybody it's going to be true
of Kevin McCarthy If he if he becomes a
speaker it's going to be true of Andy
Biggs if he became the speaker be true
be true of Jim Jordan and looking at
history right now looking at the times
that Kevin McCarthy has been up for this
job
and and looking at Jim Jordan emerging
as a potential compromised candidate or
some other names have been floated as
well but Jim Jordan is probably leading
the bunch
I don't know it seems certainly
plausible if not likely that you get a
compromise candidate type to take the
reins from McCarthy if McCarthy cannot
command the number of votes that are
needed
to win the speakership okay which he
wasn't able to do last time and he
wasn't able to do yesterday
so maybe the Republicans seriously have
to consider an alternative I don't get
all that riled up about these house
leadership elections because my job as a
citizen is to elect the congressman
that's what I have to do but these
elections are for the congressmen to
elect their leadership
and that's a different sort of thing and
it requires a different skill set and so
I leave it up to the members but I'm
certainly not going to cast again any
members of the House Freedom caucus for
saying no we want a different leader and
the guy that 85 of the conference is
pushing is not acceptable to us I have
no problem with that at all that is that
is democracy in action my friends I see
no problem with that what so ever
[Music]
[Music]